تنظر ما تعرف بلجنه الافراج المبكر
التابعه لمصلحه السجون الاسرائيليه في طلب
للافراج عن الاسير وليد دقه البالغ من
العمر 62 عاما في اعقاب تدهور جديد في
حالته الصحيه ونقله يوم امس الاول الى قسم
العنايه المركزه وكانت النيابه
الاسرائيليه العامه اعلنت انها ستعارض
الافراج عن الاسير دقه المصاب بالسرطان
ويقمع الاسير في سجون الاحتلال منذ 38
عاما
معنى من امام السجن الرمله مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري نجوان مرحبا بك اذا اطلعينا
على تطورات في قضيه الاسير دقه سواء فيما
يتعلق بالمحاكمه او وضعه الصحي في
المستشفى
نعم حاله الاسير وليد دقه تعرف بانها حرجه
للغايه الاسير وليد دقه تم تشخيصه في
نهايه العام الماضي باصابته بنوع نادر من
امراض السرطان اجيت له في اعقاب ذلك عمليه
ولكن هناك مضاعفات خطيره وقد ترد وضعه
الصحي وقبل ايام قليله تم نقله الى قسم
العنايه المكثفه في احدى المستشفيات جنوب
مدينه تل ابيب لكن بطبيعه الحال حتى الان
تمنع العائله من زيارته خلال الاشهر
الاخيره نقل عده مرات الى المستشفى ولكن
غالبيه الوقت كان يخضع للعلاج فيما يعرف
بعياده سجن الرملي وبطبيعه الحال هي غير
مؤهله لمنحه هذا النوع من العلاج لهذا
النوع من المرض النادر حاليا في محكمه هذا
السجن يتم التباحث في قضيه امكانيه
الافراج مبكر عنه ونحن لا نتحدث عن افراج
مبكر بمعنى ان من محكوميته الاولى
الاسير دقه قد وانتهت محكوميته الاولى 37
عاما قد في السجون
ولكن بعد قبل او في عام 2018 تم اضافه
عامين اخرين على محكوميته بتهمه مشاركته
في ادخال هواتف نقاله لاسرى وعمليا هذين
العامين لا يخضعان لما يعرف في اسرائيل
بتهمه امنيه وانما هي تهمه عاديه ويمكن
الطلب للافراج المبكر عنه نظرا لحالاته
الصحيه الصعبه
للغايه لكن هناك حمله تحريض واسعه من قبل
الاسرائيليين على امكانيه الافراج عنه
وهناك ايضا تحريض مباشر من وزير الامن
القومي لتمر بن جبير الذي ينشر طيله ضد ضد
امكانيه بحث قضيه الافراج عنه في هذه
اللجنه الى ان تحول حتى موضوع هذه اللجنه
اليوم من امكانيه الافراج المبكر عنه الى
اي مدى مخوله هذه اللجنه في بحث قضيه
الافراج المبكر عنه وانما قد يتم نقل
البحث الى لجنه اخرى تعنى في شؤون الاسرى
المتهمين في قضايا امنيه تعرف باسرائيل
قضايا ارهابيه وبالتالي حتى اليوم سيصدر
القرار فقط فيما اذا كانت هذه اللجنه
ستصدر ستصدر هذا القرار نحن نتحدث عن ابرز
الاسرى الفلسطينيين من داخل الخط الاخضر
من قبل فتره اوسلو وهو خلال فترته 37 عاما
في الاسر انتج الكثير من الكتب والمقالات
العديد من
النضالات السياسيه التي خاضها ايضا في
السجن وهو تزوج وهو داخل السجن من سناء
دقه وهي معروفه ايضا في نضالها في قضيه
الحركه الاسيره وقبل ثلاثه اعوام انجب
وليد دقه وسناء طفله من نطفه مهربه هي
ميلاد دقه حاليا ميلاد تبلغ من العمر
ثلاثه اعوام وثلاثه اشهر وهي تشارك
والدتها بطبيعه الحال في كافه الوقفات
والمظاهرات من اجل الافراج من اجل انقاذ
حياه والدها وهو كما ذكرنا قد انهى
المحكوميه التي فرضت عليه عليه عندما سجن
في عام 1986 شكرا جزيلا لك من امام سجن
الرمله نجوان سمري